my name is Pamela Smith I am chair of
the history department this year and I
am very pleased to welcome you to thank
you to the department's second doctor s
TB lecture in history dr. Singh to meet
with born in tent bar in 1923 and his
generous philanthropy extended not only
to numerous gifts to universities and
university libraries in particular all
over the world and also to the kind of
rather intriguing gift to the Chinese
chess Academy in Beijing but also to the
Columbia University and to the
Department of History and we've
benefited from his foresight in his
generosity in a dao endowing this
lectureship which is intended to examine
critical issues in international history
professor bullets lecture tonight its
most cultures a second opinion on the
origin of civilization takes us far back
in time and seems probably at first
glance to many of you very far removed
from present-day critical issues
national history but that's why I'm sure
you came to this box sponsored by the
history department tonight because we
know and you know that analysis of
critical issues in the present depend
upon understanding that complex causes
of how we got here how these issues came
into being and the present and
particularly relevant in professor
Bullock's lecture tonight in the present
day uses and conceptualizations of such
fundamental widely use and problematic
concepts as civilization for but
professor bullet will provide an
original way to think about this
extremely flawed term just as he did in
this 2004 book the case for Islamic
Christian civilization but I'm
overstepping my mandate here I am not
supposed to introduce professor bullets
I stab instead the very lucky privilege
of praising not just one of my
extraordinary colleagues but in fact two
of them
I'm professor bullet will be introduced
by Russian kanui the Edward Sayid
professor of modern Arab studies
two bullets longtime colleague and
equally prolific scholar in the history
of the Middle East
professor Khalid he received his BA from
Yale as he filled from Oxford in 1974
and in addition to his very long distant
works including recently 2006 book on
the iron cage Palestinian struggle for
statehood
he's 2009 so in crisis American
dominance and both war and I have it you
probably don't know this now yet but he
has a book just about to be released
early next year from beacon press
brokers of deceit how the US has
undermined peace in the Middle East in
addition to these widely discussed and
prize-winning books and articles Mexico
TV also edits the journal of Palestine
studies is past president of Middle East
Studies Association and worked as well
as an advisor to the Palestinian
bitter and the heat is funny to leave
the it is it is a occasion for me to
reflect on the fact you know I've been
calling since I was here earlier and
it's not the least surprising to me
it's topic it's miss cultures a second
opinion on the origin of civilization is
not shall we say an arrow Oh
the nature of the map take on something
serious this is a this is a scholar who
has been associated with our university
for over 36 years he's taught at
Columbia for 36 years he got his BA from
Harvard a full 50 years ago I learned
from that CD today and his PhD 45 years
versity its supervising there was that
side of it so you didn't the supervisor
there was a chair up give the greatest
orientalist of this generation of
several generations was the teacher
there and also the teacher of the people
who basically established Middle East
Studies modernist history several others
or the teacher people are now
many important institutions all over the
world not just in this country not just
in Europe Israel yeah world Iran all
over weather gear boarding schools these
are
really helped to create a field and dick
is where the most distinguished not
going to go through the pages from
honors or the pages of books I will
mention that he had seven what I would
argue truly major those are the things
that made this scholar the thing that I
think many big bullets the most one of
the most extraordinary features teaching
on field are the other books on history
of the 22 Columbia history of the 20th
century high school college that's the
global history a book entitled a crisis
in the Middle East which is a high
school supplementary Carter Maslan
well you may conclude those facts he
reached more people than most of us in
this room to that kind of work and the
dozens of hundreds of teenagers the
dozens the hundreds of lectures he gave
all over the country and not just at
Harvard where of course use a visitor
but at high schools and South Mountain
and Civic Center um I notice the same
so I think I don't anymore I guess I
could I could talk for quite a good
years but I think he has a lot to say so
why don't I just let him say he's told
me he wants a very long time so I will
leave you to the master dick
thank you in my 36 years at Columbia was
the first time I've been invited to give
a major lecture I'm delighted with how
many people who have come my colleagues
in the history department and
particularly my doctoral students from
previous years it's just a pleasure to
see a wall and to see how many people
feel very close to and who will forgive
me for whatever I say the idea of
talking about the origins of
civilization arose two years ago about
this time when I talked for the first
time last time a lecture course on the
history of world I decided that that
lecture course would be my one foray
into the field so I haven't videos made
of it and put them on YouTube for anyone
to look at so if you want to get a lot
more of the kind of stuff
I'll have today you can always go
look at YouTube just type my name in
there all these all these pictures
whoever the reason it arose at that time
was B it was compounded because of the
world history textbook that was she
mentioned where one of the issues that
are Rises totally for my textbook for
that all other textbook writers is in an
American classroom let's say an AP
course in high school when you have a
substantial number of people of Hispanic
back down in the class they become kind
of discontent when they find they aren't
mentioned until chapter 12 whereas the
people in the least the people in Europe
the people in the they had all this
early stuff and then kind of as an
afterthought
well Columbus is coming up so we better
do something about them Incas and the
mass text so that it doesn't appear to
be that there was nothing going on in
the in the Western Hemisphere and I
became
puzzled by how you could make this world
history actually a world history prior
to Columbus and as I thought about it I
became intrigued by a notion that the
English archaeologist Colin Renfrew has
written about in a rather flamboyant
fashion and offended a lot and it's what
he calls the sapient paradox assigment
paradox is a paradox that arises when
people who are siient as we are because
we are Homo sapiens aliens do not act
save you in other words when people who
are genetically evolutionarily wise do
not do wise things and the wise thing
that they don't do is create
civilization so what ran through talks
about what he calls the Stadion paradox
is that the consensus of archaeologists
and neuroscientists is that by sixty
thousand years ago if somewhere between
that
very elusive things right but let's say
sixty thousand years ago Homo sapiens
sapiens came into being as a subspecies
in East Africa with all of the cognitive
capacities that we have done other words
we act on this on the premise days that
who we are is who they were and it's all
been one species since that time now
we're the products of civilization were
very proud of it despite everything and
what Renfrew was said was why did it
take so damn long for these people who
have all of the cognitive capacities
that we have to come up with the idea of
civilization
well it's an intriguing not question it
is a tricky question because it assumes
that civilization is isn't achievable
good as opposed to being a sort of but
what I found particularly intriguing and
as far as I can tell no one else has
made this observation is that when is
that when you compare the new world with
the old world
oh yes there we will say paradox and
it's on the handout that you have if you
count backwards from the present you say
what were the earliest civilizations
there is a consensus the earliest
civilizations that was to say urban
concentrate an agricultural base
societies that have writing and class
divisions and so focus on the earliest
civilizations were in Egypt in
Mesopotamia and in the Indus Valley of
southern Pakistan roughly the same time
all of them are rich mating let us say
around 3,500 BC or 5500 years before the
present if you
look at that you'll find that the early
civilizations in the in the Western
Hemisphere are really not really not
comparable at all
the Olmecs the humming culture and
northern Peru maybe 1500 BC so it's a
big difference and so when you read
textbooks they're never brought into the
same frankly because we the Western
Hemisphere is it's so much later than
the eastern hemisphere but if you help
the other way around you say you cannot
have a civilization until you have a
killing population and then if you say
when did the human population first
appear and to say the human population
of Homo sapiens sapiens not the
Neanderthals not the Homo erectus or
other earlier versions of humankind but
if you say when did homo sapiens sapiens
first arrived then you find that the gap
in time between the first arrival of
homo sapiens sapiens in Egypt
Mesopotamia southern indus valley in
pakistan
there's roughly 40,000 years ago and so
the the gap in time between the earliest
appearance
oh this species that we belong to having
the first manifestations of civilization
there's about thirty one thousand years
if you look at the Western Hemisphere
where the current consensus is that Homo
sapiens sapiens arrived in the Americas
around 15,000 years ago rather than
4,000 years ago and you find that from
that time to the first urban remains we
have significance archaeologically you
have thirteen thousand four hundred
years now what this means is people in
the Western Hemisphere arrived at
civilization twenty thousand years
faster than people the eastern
hemisphere
so that even if the Egyptians and the
best Athenians and the people there is
not civilization appeared for us to be
very alert and very creative they were
also very very slow they just couldn't
get the job done for tens of thousands
of years whereas those people who
fetched them in Western Hemisphere
somehow they caught on to the idea of
civilization much faster like twenty
thousand years faster now the trick
there is that you have to assume that
your starting point is basically one of
equality and slowly but the obvious
answer to this seeding discrepancy would
be to say well those people who arrived
in the Americas were already on their
way and therefore there wasn't all that
much to do - yeah up to civilization but
but that really doesn't work because DNA
analysis has shown that the forerunners
of the first migrants to the new world
were not Chinese and Southeast Asians
and Indians who were who may have been
pondering maybe you should get civilized
well then you will wait a while but
rather they were thee their nearest
relatives are the trip Chiefs in the
same way ants and the other people of
Northeast Siberia
who to this day haven't yet decided that
they want to have any civilization of
their own
moreover at the time these first people
arrived in the new world they have no
domesticated plants no domesticated
animals so that if there was some
something they were preparing for it's
very hard to see any what it would be
because in 15,000 15,000 years ago
whether he's were in the new world of
the old world you were living in Stone
Age with little to anything that
civilization would just just around the
corner if you were thousand years so so
the question is why was civilizations so
accelerated in the new world and so
party in the old world well from the
point of view of the first opinion on
the original civilization of the one
that might imply exists because I'm
giving the second thing from that point
the first opinion is that there was a
particular area that had wild wheat and
bark
why don't we even barley along with
sheep and goats and cows they can put
those together with people and you stir
and mix for only twenty thousand years
and lo and behold you will get
civilization and virtually every
textbook of Oh 20 years ago
what sort of took this for granted you
have the great Fertile Crescent this is
where the wheat and barley is grown and
people would write if you grew wheat and
barley you would have a high production
of calories per acre you would have a
storable crop and you would therefore
have a denser population and people
would come together and they would
create civilization that civilization
would depend upon the her ability to
domesticate crops not just wheat barley
would eventually other crops and their
ability to domesticate animals now there
is virtually no aspect of that sort of
wonderful moment of Neolithic
civilizational revolution taking place
in Egypt Mesopotamia that is still
unchallenged and the challenges are
numerous and diverse and if you get into
the literature you discover that that
first view is almost unhittable anyone
the challenges are so far for example
virtually every text book will tell you
the story of how if there domesticating
wheat there's just one genetic change
and it's a naturally-occurring mutation
that causes the seed either to break off
or not break off easily from the stalk
the riddle ratchets
theory they say the thing this is how
the investigation recurred and so we can
barley or some people would even say
grains in general they provided the
imagine for domesticated plants the
problem is that other plants that grow
in other parts of the world are
domesticated as early as week merly
in areas that do not thing develop
civilizations so that in an
archaeological site in New Guinea it's
been established at the same time we can
barley appeared to have been undergoing
domestication in perhaps southern turkey
you have for crops that were being
cultivated in New Guinea that produced
at least as many calories per acre as we
can borrow your sugar cane doing
terrible
you have yams and bananas
but no civilization no the sawmill
danger anything so he said okay well
maybe people the beginning was didn't
think hard about what they could do with
these domestic stuff but then you say
well in the new world ten thousand years
ago when we barley domesticated manioc
was being investigated now manioc
becomes a staple crop for many of the
new world societies and the basic
fundamental foodstuff so there was
manioc domesticated it was domesticated
in southwestern Brazil no one has ever
found and he's big stone buildings in
southwestern Brazil or any
archaeological civilization any it's a
little little less clear but it appears
that sorghum was probably domesticated
in Africa in the area of the southern
Sahara Desert around the same time
around 10,000 years ago that Emma set
tap and Ethiopia may have been
domesticated that far in the past
certainly potatoes maize were
domesticated infernal in other words a
lot of crops became controlled by human
cultivators around the same time around
ten thousand years ago
the problem is that the people who
domesticated the plants were not the
people who subsequently created urban
civilizations this was it happened
occasionally but it was not automatic
there is also in the textbooks very
frequently saying that plants and
animals were domesticated at the same
time but this was not true in in most
parts of the world so that it was true
for her sheep and goats and cattle in in
the Fertile Crescent but increasingly it
is our maintain that cattle were
probably separately domesticated and at
least two in replaces the Sahara Desert
and in Pakistan
you did not have large domestics in the
new world increasingly of the story of
domestication has come down to a story
of each animal each domestication
history is a separate history and none
of those histories in their first
generations at least
correlate with the rise of civilization
and I'll come back to this if you want
more on this on reading a book called
hunters herders and hamburgers that goes
into detail about
you know beauty
Oh
okay so this
this part of the first opinion then sort
of falls apart
let me go on to the question of how
people came to settle these different
parts of the world because there are
very peculiar questions we ask when we
say that humans modern humans Homo
sapiens sapiens were in the Middle East
40,000 years ago we can also say that
they were in Europe 40,000 years ago and
we can say they were in Australia 40,000
years ago you think gee that's a long
way from East Africa how did people get
to Australia as early as I got to Egypt
Egypt is just up the block
Europe is hardly much farther Australia
it's just a long long way away
yes
civilization yeah yeah okay
Computer History Department
administrator Patrick do you have the
login for the student
some people say it's sixty thousand
years ago I'm one with the conservative
dates but all of this okay what but the
next slide would be it would be a a map
I'm scared they're left and that's
Australia between presentation we've got
a recent items as well
No
you happy today I would point out that
you called everyone in this room
basically civilization a retarded all
the Europeans all the Middle Easterners
anyone who is in terms of American he
basically said it's low civilization I
think it takes a lot of guts
but then that implies that civilization
was good yeah that advice so it feels
good but if we assume that then we're
also those they actually slow well I
think that's true I think there's lots
of evidence to support anyway if you
look at a map of the world of around
40,000 years ago you are looking at the
environment that is the ice age or one
of the ice ages and therefore it has
completely different
all right
this is a very sketchy effort to show
what the world looked like when the sea
level was perhaps 400 feet below where
it is found and one of the things that
is most evident is that Southeast Asia
was a subcontinent it's often referred
to as sundaland by geologists and
Australia New Guinea or another
subcontinent separated by the small
straight of some sort and that's often
called suckle and but the reason I'm
showing this is because if you if you
look at East Africa you see that's the
red sea is that sort of laws manage
going up you can see that the Middle
East and Egypt are very very close for
that matter Pakistan is rather closer
it's India's sticking down and Pakistan
owes the left part of that yeah
and Europe is not very far away now you
look at Australia anything how does he
look out there the answer to that would
appear to me
okay
here's out of Africa this we're almost
sapiens sapiens da someone up this way
someone over here someone up here and
some end up over here now the question
is why did they get to Australia as fast
if you know if you go if you're walking
this is you know following if you follow
the coastline
it's maybe 10,000 bucks atoms of 20,000
years together
if 40,000 years is right which would
mean that people would expand about five
miles every 10 years not such an
enormous thing to do on a gradual basis
but then when you look at textbooks what
they happen they usually show sweeping
arrows across here and up here
all of which follow the interior because
we have been led to think that our
earliest forebears were big-game hunters
you know they hunted mammoths they
hunted cave bears and so forth and so on
but you have to give that some thought
but I was teaching my course on the
history of domestic animals one of the
things I would ask early on of course
was if you have know if you were a human
early human and you had no tools all you
had were your teeth and your nails and
your legs and you wanted to start eating
meat what would you eat and how would
you get it the football players would
say hi grandpa
reindeer freaking step kill reindeer and
I say fine how do you get inside because
it's covered with leather and well I I
wait for lying to come along and it open
it up for me
and generally the class would occur that
humans are you carry that we killed by
other animals that were predators who do
not require special tools but then the
problem is what do you eat once you're
inside chewing on muscle
which we call safe is really unpleasant
if it hasn't been cooked and cooking was
not automatic early and so the general
consensus is that you eat the soft tips
the brain the eyeballs the the testicles
I usually got eyes on classes and so
forth and you know organ meats the
things people don't normally today we
prefer to do muscle but the real answer
is not that we went to and we ate these
big animals that we could track down and
kill but too large creating small
animals though easier to get inside and
these are catch though the squirrels and
rabbits and so forth but mainly we ate
the fish easiest things to eat our
shellfish and other marine life
including fish the problem is
archaeologically
these don't leave a lot of remains
particularly since they are primarily
along the coast and the coast becomes
submerged once the ice age passes and
the sea level rises so what I'm
suggesting is that people did indeed
walk from here to Australia they
followed the Cubs of mountains and the
interior and the interior they follow
the coast and they eat the seafood and
notice that even today in the clambake
you don't have to have an open fire but
you don't have to have a vessel and dig
a hole in the sand you're lined with
stones a very primitive way of cooking
even its latest when Europeans arrived
in the new world in new england in the
intertidal area and the tide went out
the place was crawling with lobsters
well you just went and picked one out
these were not hard to find and the
evidence for the eating of these things
are called shell middens which are
basically huge piles of shells that are
left from the earliest periods in those
areas that did that become subsequently
submerged so that
at one early site in Southeast Asia they
found 46 feet bones well that's pretty
good that's oh that dates but they have
a shell dividend that was seven meters
deep in solid shells the evidence of
eating of crustaceans and mollusks and
fish if you have shells is a nervous
bone-stock so much well the earliest
bones from Southeast Asia nearly as long
in Southeast Asia is a big fish well it
turns it up now back there is a new
technique of discovering how much fish
people ate and this is an analysis of
nitrogen isotopes that can be recovered
from the bones left by humans and
animals nitrogen comes in two long
lasting isotopes nitrogen 14 and
nitrogen 15 neither is radioactive
they're just the two different versions
of nitrogen and they are produced by
plants that take the nitrogen out of the
atmosphere so the ratio of 14 to 15 in
the plants will reflect the ratio 14 to
15 in the atmosphere
animals cannot take nitrogen from the
atmosphere all the nitrogen that we have
in our body is for sure absolutely
necessary for our life comes from
directly or indirectly from the plants
them eat now if we eat nothing but
plants then you can look at our nitrogen
ratio 14 and 15 and that will be
reflected but both will be reflection is
exactly the same fashion because all
animals appear to excrete nitrogen 14
and 15 at different rates so that you
will have a little bit more of 15 when
you have a fourteenth if you have
nothing the plants if you eat animals
beneath the plants the animals will have
a little bit more 15 and 14 and you
eating animals you'll end up with a
little still a little bit more 15 114
because you're getting your nitrogen
through the animals as well as your
whatever massery now in
in marine biology where you have many
many more letter layers of big fish eat
little fish where did you bitty fish
yeah slightly bigger fish favorite fish
you have so many levels of economic
levels are called of the food chain that
was the very top of the food chain the
disproportion of 14 to 15 is very was
very striking this is the same process
that causes certain chemicals to
concentrated in tuna fish and other and
other yeah organisms are toward the top
of the food chain so if people eat the
fish primarily they won't have a 14 to
15 ratio that reflects officially rather
than the ratio they would have if
they've been eating sheep and goats
which are simply one step away from the
vegetation itself so result is that
flower we have looked archaeologically
for for the last several generations
that Bowman assemblages and said the
bones will tell what the pattern of
sustenance was for these people it's not
even even possible to look at the
difference between let us say animal
bones human bones so that for
people living up in this area Ukraine
and Romania in 45 thousand BC which was
say what we call the old European
civilization because it was not a fully
urban civilization but it was a very
developed Neolithic culture
it's now been argued that if you compare
the the nitrogen ratio for the animals
the sheep from the goats of the nitrogen
ratio for the humans you can determine
that 60% of the animal protein that
these people in Ukraine and Romania are
consumed not was from fish and the
likelihood is that humans everywhere
were very big eaters of fish and
mollusks and crustaceans enormous number
of shell middens appear here in
Southeast Asia and what it suggests is
that people followed the coast rather
than moving inland following migratory
animals not all of them some of them
tonight the validity of that archaeology
is saying that there's a submerged
coastal archaeology that reflects a
different model which is following the
fit so you go from here and go along
again through Southeast Asia
then what do you do you go off the
Pacific coast
here's Japan you go up it goes across
here they come down here down here and
down here to Peru Peru has the most
abundant fisheries
and the highest levels of fish
consumption that have been found
archaeologically about human goals are
improved from a mummy of 5000 years ago
so so you think well maybe our
concentration on big-game hunters kinda
misses the point
if for example you figure that people
went 10,000 miles in 20,000 years and
then you figure it's another 20,000
miles to get to Peru well it's going to
take you into about 15,000 years ago in
order to get there in other words this
is a very plausible explanation and it's
pretty much fish all the way I mean
Japan
you know big fish something season week
fish
Washington lead salmon you get down to
you know San Diego in the tuna industry
we finding it out into Peru and you got
this massive amount of anchovies we
don't know much about climate impact on
fishers but one thing that is fairly
clear we think there is that there's a
strong correlation between abundant fish
and cold water so that the cold currents
that well up along the peruvian coast
produce enormous pots of fish and so
from japan up across the Bering Strait
and down the the Glacial coast of Alaska
and Canada and on to the Americas these
are cold currents for the most part
particular type of swimming in San
Francisco and these were very no really
great fishing areas it's just that so
much of that land where they might have
left ideological traces then comes some
beneath the sea
all right so humans dispersed they went
all over the world and then at a certain
point they they build cities in the
that's a in the old world this is the
earliest you know major or not an urban
center about stone mill site this is him
southern Turkey maybe the place called
good back lid check that outside the
floor fire if Jericho had a stone wall
of roughly the same age but you head
into the Beck live downtown is 30
circular structures with enormous stone
uprights each one weighing somewhere in
the order of six or seven tons EMA on a
hilltop in an environment in which there
were no domestic plants no domestic
animals no ceramics and no tools other
than stone and yet this complex but
there's a ritual complex we don't know
only four of the circles have been
excavated so far with this complex it
required a phenomenal amount of Labor
organized to a common purpose something
that we have normally attributed to
civilization and to the ability of
certain people to command the surplus of
agricultural production for some sort of
collective purpose but here there was
though crop surplus to be collected in
the way that we
associated with Egypt or Mesopotamia
this is a hunting and gathering Society
this is the earliest statue of a person
so far as we know in the world it is
from Gobekli attempt at there is another
image there similar to it that it was
inscribed as a bob relief on one of the
uprights in the site of the length let's
check that and it's quite apparent that
these people were hunters the one that
is still in the site has the man wearing
an animal skin to wrap this around his
waist this is pretty much life-size
maybe five feet tall everything
ibrahim i my friends arranged for me to
go there earlier the summer so
absolutely spectacular place that we
become one of the great world
archaeological centers in the next of
the coming years okay so this is a big
stone mill site without domestic plants
or animals and no ceramics in the new
world the comparable site is
in the Peruvian desert it's called
Corral six pyramids a whole bunch of
elaborate structures there are a lot of
village sites around there and this this
goes back you can see from here return
here to to around 2600 BC so it's much
later than go back to attempt time and
yet it's strikingly similar
you know stone built circular structures
and so forth if you have art showing up
in the back lift up then you'll have
music showing up at chorale leave this
is a collection of 36 whistles or flutes
that have been big they're made on
Republican boats
now these are human populations totally
different parts of the world separated
by thousands of years and totally
different traditions again when it comes
to to art music and so forth this is
where this notion about the species is
all one and does the same thing
everywhere arises that you have too much
parallelism not not to have
but wrong spaces so my conclusion is
that if it took 40,000 years to get to
go back with tempeh and it took only
13,000 aiders get to Kurama and if the
existing notion that domesticated plants
automatically produce civilization if
that is not valid then what happened
it's now commonly thought that hunters
and gatherers in different parts of the
world moved into a stage of using plants
that they controlled whether they were
grains or roots or tree crops whatever
loves and lived a stable life without
ever moving past the basic hunting ever
hunters and gatherers there's a
consensus tangley that they live much
healthier lives than civilized farmers
did for example they have you know
dental problems are almost non-existent
cavities came in with the famous they
live healthier lives they lived in very
egalitarian societies and they didn't
work very hard civilization man who were
unhealthy you work your ass off and
there was no egalitarian stuff at all
but it was the 99% and the 1% so so the
question is what civilization at the
time as a great that people could not
anticipate what the consequences would
be
but civilization was stepped forward or
was it a miserable way of life that
people fell into for some reason but
most people managed to avoid now I'm
inclined to think that it was something
that people fell into because they
couldn't avoid why couldn't they live
and this gets to this call you the back
people dispersing around the globe no
other species of animal has dispersed
everywhere only mom why did people go
everywhere
they didn't know whether they were to
find one thing we know is that they
would continually be moving out of the
flora pattern of things runners now you
can say okay here's a group say the some
hunters and gatherers the Philippines or
South Africa and they collect seeds or
roots or leaves from 150 different
plants and that's what they clutch but
if they moved 200 miles north 75 of
those plants aren't growing any more
everywhere people left they were
continually faced with new plants most
plants we can't let just a fairly big
subset of them will kill us and those
that don't kill us will often taste just
terrible so people did not move into new
areas in order to sample the plant life
so over time they learned about plant
life this is one of the characteristics
humans they learn in plant life where
they weigh and they're very very
different things so that for example new
world where that where you have take
3,000 species of cactus 40 of them will
will make you high and give you a
relations he and the people found out
about 40 of them
that means they tried all 35 all 3000
you know two guys went out and said
Miguel I'm going to eat this fight diet
tell if it's insipid we'll leave it but
if I really get high I'll tell you the
desire to get to have hallucinations is
one of the big differences between the
new world Milberg really stupidest
substance you know you know after the
next warning you don't say oh what a
great drunk I had last night you say how
miserable I feel but you know after some
hallucinations so people had to learn in
the flora everywhere they went
well that's time-consuming it's
dangerous but what makes it possible is
that almost all flesh is edible so the
people who dispersed around the world
support of themselves by eating
organisms for whether it was shellfish
or regular fish or mammoths whatever
once they eat the meat and then
gradually they will add garnish for us
from Texas and reports or your father
says the vegetables with the steak are
what the snake eats not human food
humans eat meat and that's I think
warmest true that eating meat closely
the key to his personal appearance
making impossible
that's just why do people watch it is
first and this gets him to a kind of
philosophical issue it is often assumed
that people defend their territories
that conflict and warfare and killing
are innate
because people will will hold on to
their homeland and they will only leave
the homeland if you track their
existence of strength if they stay I
have inclined to think that that's wrong
there's very little evidence for very
little evidence for the strike Steven
Pinker's new book I have been playing of
things that people don't like to hang
around of other people very much now
that you know if you can see another
campsite it's getting too crowded and
you'd better move on down the beach and
try some new territory I think Anna
mystically even today
people men in particular think I'd like
to do kind of vote and just go out
sailing for the next five years or I
want to go to a place in New Hampshire
where it's only me or Adams I know I'm
going to walk the Appalachian Trail from
one man to another and hope I don't see
anybody else the the number of human
males who are so poorly socialized so to
say that they really want to be away and
probably rivals the number of male
orangutan who live proportionately who
live totally solitary lives than before
there's no particular reason to assume
that humans are as social or whereas
social 60,000 years ago as they have now
now if that's the case then the question
is if there's they began to disperse
what do you do if there's no place to
disperse to what do you do if you are so
confined geographically that there is no
place to go and that is the case in the
New World
so the first civilizations were in along
the peruvian coast which is a very
narrow strip of desert between marcus
lee abundant pacific fishing location
and the high Andes
and there's no place to go you can climb
the mountains you can go dorks up
there's no there's really no place to
expand and this is where you get
the first civilization the southeastern
Mexico where the Olmecs / similarly
confined between the Caribbean fishery
along the coast and mountains behind the
coast and this is where you get the
first the first civilizations in the new
world now I'm going to call those
issuances in other words either very
narrowly confined spaces but when it
comes to the old world there's always
someplace to go
you go back to this to this map and
you know the river valleys there in red
are where the civilizations are is the
green is where you have crops think
domesticated but there's only certain
river valleys that does about
civilization so that the river valleys
of Romania and Ukraine which of the
senator of the old European civilization
after after 4000 BC the people dispersed
the Neolithic in China dispersed around
the same time around 4000 BC it was only
in these particular river valleys the by
our Tigris Euphrates and the illness
that again civilization now what is the
common characteristic of these prior to
5000 BC these were surrounded by
grasslands the Sahara Desert Arabia
Simms Rajasthan these are grassy areas
full of wildlife full of people and then
no matter climate change the began
in which there was a very very mark
drying up of the climate between 5,000
and 2500 BC that caused the Sahara
Desert to open up the Arabian deserts
and its extensions into Syria Iraq to
open up and the deserts of southern
Pakistan of Northwest Indians over these
mountain deserts before that time and
effectively what happened was that river
valleys and that once been rather
undesirable swamps in the midst of these
drastic claims they become the only
places where people can go they become
explosives not dismisses between seas
for this was between between deserts if
you ever go to Egypt and you stand in
the desert on one side of the Nile and
you look across you can see the desert
on the other side of the aisle and
everybody needs a pollutes in between
can that five miles or so along the
river there's no other place you can
live except a marginally and always eats
here and there in the western desert
so what happened I I think is that those
places that were the most narrowly
confined were the places where people
were compelled to live in proximity to
one another now the real test case in a
sense but were two one is two of the
most flourishing Neolithic societies
Neolithic societies that you have when
this drying up began say 5000 BC two of
the most flourishing here with the
societies for northern China the North
China Plain and in Ukraine and in
Romania but you did not get deserts
developing there the climate changed the
climate materially and the people
dispersed it is only in places where you
have full desert development that people
are forced to live in the in the river
meadows so that I think that it is the
constriction of human settlers that is
the creek is the prerequisite for the
first civilizations rather than either
plant or animal investigation or some
sort of innate superiority of population
now
the testee the second test case will be
Southeast Asian Southeast Asia on this
map is simply a subcontinent gradually
it becomes a great system of islands
over time one has to realize that you
know that islands that we see you know a
hundred two hundred meters away where
their grandfather said we're 200 meters
away is now a half mile away but moving
between islands when you assume that the
islands were all larger much closer
together
prior to the horizon sea level you could
disperse
you couldn't disperse overland but you
could disperse over water so there is a
very strong aggregation we made
seafaring begins in in Southeast Asian
history of sail design a fascinating
story
to suggest that this is where seafaring
will end up and that the seeds of what
becomes the whole colonial expansion of
Polynesians sparse you know
Hawaii and Easter Island is Caesar being
sown back at that time actually as the
the sea level rises on these islands
come into being so I think you have a
different notions of what dystocia lives
in some cases you might just burst
inland some cases you might disperse
power from the coastline some cases you
might dispersed by water but the idea
that humans desire to disperse I think
is hard to it's hard to avoid whereas we
have really nothing about evolutions
tanning struggles over over turf and
these very early periods now let me
point to one final thing this is
particularly puzzling if you go back to
this chart you find that from the first
Paleolithic settlers in what we come the
river valley distances 40,000 years ago
and the first stone built site do that
lift a pound Jericho
last thirty thousand years plus then you
have another fifty five hundred years
before you get Egypt and Mesopotamia on
developing their civilizations that's
not nearly as long as thirty one
thousand years but it's a substantial
period of time now look at the western
hemisphere it takes thirteen thousand
years to get to the corral you get to
that first
Stoneville urban type site and then only
2,500 years half length of time to get
to major full-fledged urban you know
urban civilizations the precocity of the
Western Hemisphere continues you can say
well okay you take fifty five hundred
years to get to the point but we have
the origins of writing in Mesopotamia
but you only took twenty five hundred
years to get from corral to the origins
of writing among the Olmecs the question
is why was there such plate of the
precocious development
continue when the issue of discuses is
no longer questioners you've now
established a civilizational pattern of
some kind and I suggest here that we go
back and look at the issue of domestic
animals even the best camels don't exist
immunity and they significantly and they
are everywhere in the old world and we
assume that the best animals are a good
thing because that's what we eat for
dinner and that surely is a good thing
but there's a lot of questions raised
about domestic animals the new world is
often cultivating sort of clever
restrictions that didn't have in the
areas where she was who initial
developing them to have any animals
suitable for domestication but maybe
that was one of the great things
maybe domestic animals were a retardant
of civilization
when you look at that gap of 5,500 years
you say you know the first animal
domestication is going to be somewhere
around 80,000 years ago and then the
first truly agricultural extensive urban
civilization it's going to be around 55
let's say a 3,000 year cap well
looked-after the point of view of
domestic animals that gap is very
interesting because we all think of
cattle in particular as pulling plows
but capital didn't hold plows when they
were first domesticated it was something
like three or four thousand years before
cattle started to pull plows people did
not drink milk
when sheep and goats and cattle or first
investigation they didn't use wool when
sheep or first investigated because
sheep they're producing more what they
all produced was meat the development of
wool and
fiber in general and milk products and
labor utility are all part of what
students and investigation called
secondary secondary domestic utilities
other words these are things that were
not anticipated without anticipated when
the animals first came under control but
they developed over the course of time
the use of cattle for power which then
gives rise to the invention of wheeled
vehicles dates from around 4000 BC not
from the period when cattle first
investigated about 8,000 BC
there is a big question people were
living on their miserable harvests of
wheat barley for four thousand years
before they had any oxen to plow up the
fields they were doing why did they want
to have an ox and who owned the Ox
what I believe how he was the case but
the people who own the animals created
civilization by forcing the farmers to
use oxen and grow more grain which then
the Box owners would would take control
of so the one of the problems is that
these animals also created diseases many
of our most important diseases come into
human circulation through domestic
animals we all know this the started
they be closed when the Europeans
arrived new world they have these
diseases originating from domestic
animals that killed off 80 90 percent of
the world population but somehow we
never asked whether those diseases
originally killed off 80 or 90% of the
people who are living with the animals
when they were first must've hated you
say only Europeans developed immunities
we don't develop immunities until most
people have died so one of the things
that I think is likely is that there
were disease vectors that retarded the
growth of civilization and we're
directly associated
developing a way of cohabiting with
domestic animals
well secondly once you have developed
domestic animal patterns one of the most
common developments is that you will
develop past year old herding and
nothing screws up a civilization quite
so much as having a bunch of animal
raising nomads coming in and killing
everybody never happens in the new world
you know
the Aztecs of his voltec might go at it
over and over again to kill one another
but they're not going to be rated by
someone with 500,000 sheep but they're
trying to to fetus it's just you know
the the animal husbandry side of things
I suspect was a major return through
disease and through competition between
settled people and herders so so I'm
inclined to think that the new world may
not have any ours was in a much better
situation than the old world but it did
not close unless the kid rates one
additional factor that the Europeans
later found
interesting inscribed probably too much
importance to that is that if you don't
have domestic animals and something
occurs or you need to have a blood
sacrifice who's it gonna be
and then call the Ghostbusters it's you
know you have to kill something to
placate whatever spirits are up there or
to to get a heavenly spiritual world and
if you can't kill an animal well then
you you just got to kill one of you
so that the Europeans found that human
sacrifice was a hallmark of new world
savagery and it never occurred to them
that their own sacrifice of domestic
animals was in a sense safety we can
equate a new modern animal rights
activist everything as much as savagery
and this has given rise to the perennial
question in studies of animal
domestication as to whether animal
sacrifice in the old world is preceded
by human sacrifice almost every culture
we know um had human sacrifice very very
early on the question is whether the
sacrifice of sheep and goats and cattle
and so forth was a substitute for an
earlier era of
human sacrifice but in any case this is
because they say this is speculative the
entire actually but but my point is that
I think that when we form a look at the
east share of the western hemispheres
from the point of view of the earliest
civilizations from the plenty of
domestic plants animals and point of
view of the nature of the urban
civilizations and their first beginnings
as they occurred instead of looking
exclusively the old world because it's
early that we really have to look at
them together and say this is the
experience of humankind coming out of
the Paleolithic era and the chronology
is not really terribly important what's
important is what people do because you
know nobody in Yucatan knew they were
peering into Egypt nobody in Egypt move
the really irritated was not that long
some people but I think that what we
have done
it's created a world history and I am
China in popular textbooks including my
own that that really short changes the
Western Hemisphere and the degree short
change of Southeast Asia
and southern China virtually unmentioned
in this whole kind of history and I
think that world history is in a stage
where there's a great risk of sort of a
premature ossification a premature
agreement that there are certain things
that are recorded world history and then
forget the rest and I think this is
Whaley to her I think that we should be
reopening the whole concept of the of
the world in synchronous or asynchronous
development in order to to rediscover
some of these parallels and similarities
and paradoxes that are really clearly
there in the records and I now need to
be engrossed in to a better and more
inclusive
one is in the Western Hemisphere
you didn't say why why developed by
lions
what was it with their climate change
there as well see I think once I think
once you get your first urban structures
that there is a they could have know
about whether it's good that that's at
that or to tell you or Corral there's a
model there of some sort of centralized
exploitation of collective labor that
that becomes almost inaccessible that
you're going to get divisions of labor
that will then provide a template for
future developments whether to improve
but it's the Mexico now by comparison
for example in old European civilization
of Ukraine in Romania if you go back to
say 3500 BC there were there were
settlements focused settlements in
Ukraine that were larger than any
Sumerian city in terms of population but
that showed no internal differentiation
in terms of wealth or possessions so
that you didn't have highly
differentiated great Goods indicating
Chiefs and followers you have the same
functions were displayed in pretty much
all of the all the residences you have a
great concentration of people but you
did not have that move into a into the
99% of the 1% in which you're going to
be able to command the labor that would
turn that into a city once you could do
that I think it became a almost
obsessive for some people to do it
right and yet in the Fertile Crescent
things suddenly became much more intense
because of the climate change rights
assessment so have a good megalith and
good McClinton it's like early Neolithic
China before 4000 or old Europe you have
structures you don't have much evidence
of so far of a social differentiation in
the same way for example the roots don't
have we don't have much evidence of a
social differentiation there is a site
in northern Sudan west of the Nile River
on their desert called
not apply where you similarly have some
large some structures that that don't
appear to be accompanied by movements
for the ongoing command of labor so we
don't know how good if I came to be
there and yet did that come about the
claimant I think study said they have to
be more yet yeah I just I think you're
missing what do these question is
because you said these are get some
cement symbols they jumped right but
this point was that the Isthmus is
formed in Mesoamerica by the boundaries
of the mountains of the other things so
they're humans are squeezed and
resistance but that this is the same
instances were created with climate
change of middle east so you didn't need
the climate change that is not correct
you didn't need the climate change of
Mesoamerica created the president the
the climate change that will have him in
the older if it was global this Brian
period would have occurred in the new
world but it would not have the right
maybe the time came quite important for
these American civilization I can
understand on the inking because I'm
quite to see it for they might well the
my answer it's the Olmecs were the first
right and there you do get the topics
then the Mayans develop out of that in
the same way that choking in which a and
a goes develop above but first to person
improving desert the derivative bourbon
civilizations aren't necessarily in the
same place as we
that's the first instance that's why I
think it's a model that has an impact
though that area around corral never
again becomes a important you know urban
urbanized area it goes up into the
mountains for the next round the Lions
it goes into into the upper town
believes in places like that yesterday
one of the things that occurred to me
when I was first studying this system
many people have argued that still do
argue that on the basis of old-world
history that the temperate zones are a
scene a quantum of civilization and that
you can never have a civilization
originating in the tropics in a
rainforest and how could that ever
happen how could you have a civilization
originating in the condo and yet in the
new world you do count civilizations the
middle range for all of the
civilizations of the new world hiring
tropics
none of the civilizations of the overall
are in the tropics and and yet we
maintain a notion that the tropics are
well we use the word tropic tropical
in a way almost identical to to the word
oriental as it works I mean construe we
say well that's a tropical environment
that means that it's lethargic and have
sexual excess of health community and
health so easy living great music and
great sex of rhythm and so forth and we
certainly do not think of people in the
tropics I was having bookends because
they're they're comfortable sergeant the
thing is that Edward came from the
culture that he was identifying as the
object of derision from part of
Europeans whereas there has been known
from the tropics so far who's come along
and said we should get rid of this word
tropical because it is so insulting so
demeaning and it's exactly like the word
around and and we must be almost
immaculate but one way to to make that
point just to look at this comparison
where you can have the remnants of Mayan
horticulture in in rainforests where you
can see that it was arranged fruit tree
cultivation sort of and so on and the
proper drainage and so on and it's in
the middle of the rainforest and we have
to say you know
that potency is there whether it's
tropical or whether it's tempura and
this meant addresses the great question
that unemployment rates which was wider
than the Rio Grande developed the
civilization because it has a a River
regime very much like the time was
keyphrase
and no civilization but it was the wrong
come on the idea that human sacrifice
came before animal sacrifice was
probably illustrated by the story of
Abraham Isaac Ishmael yeah my question
is about map or clearly the head for the
hills
how do you account for procreation in
their eyes of demography Rob Roy from
the heavens came down low in order to
steal away a body like white penis house
in order
we once you once the male's disperse
they will find a way to steal themselves
a woman for another guy but it's I'm not
worried too much papa
I think we've been too focused on rhesus
monkeys and Gibbons chimpanzees and so
forth m-mother Sunnah the women raided
the children therefore worthy
influence on the running of the chin
secular experience in any way in any
case of the business of the human
sacrifice it's true that the Ibrahim
Isaac story which we know was
accompanied by human sacrifice from the
other nine groups and sort of symbolizes
that the children misery will not
continue to engage in this that's sort
of the benchmark but it's rather late in
terms of state investigation the war or
important things are things like the new
European cosmological deaths we approach
a certain amount of Vesta where you have
a human who is killed and then the whole
universe is made out of his body parts
so the skull becomes the heavens tourism
so long in different parts because of
different orders of society that's
paralleled Norse mythology by
killing of the giant in air who then
become so sourcing you know
don't have as much appearance of
domestic animals and cosmological
creator myths as you have of sacrifice
children's and I'd say almost every
society has evidence of some degree in
food sacrifice it happens that we have a
textual preservation in the Bible but
it's my party I have
this question of procedure the efficient
air you should be displayed on with them
I'm wondering whether the band that we
have been shocked to see religious tax
entity who Bible etc
maybe they didn't take the stock I hate
to say this given the nature of our
culture but I think the revivals of very
late tax with respect to all the things
I'm talking about
and so I'm disinclined to to read over
much into it and then also our reading
of the Hebrew Bible in these areas has
been powerfully affected by assumptions
that we've had about Jewish religion and
so forth and so on
they could be related to an attempt to
try to protect drilling stops maybe
others
oh I think that's scientistic
fresh now that because as unlikely it's
the idea that a prohibition on pork is
going to propel trichinosis I think
these this was
19th century former biblical commentary
that was trying to rely on the
Enlightenment that makes no sense at all
the great fundamental truth of the laws
of kashrut as I read one is that the
Jews couldn't be donkeys they couldn't
talk they couldn't eat pigs they didn't
have any things but you look at stories
of battles that we chronicles that kings
and so forth they're continually
capturing livestock of their enemies and
they'll have you know so many cattle and
so many sheep and so many donkeys
I think they can't be productions what
if they have damned on a sport like you
need 5,000 monkeys but there is a verse
in the Torah that is parallel to the
story of Abraham and Isaac it says you
must sacrifice the firstborn of all of
your domestic animals except the dog
from hitted from sacrificing the
firstborn of your donkey but you must
sacrifice a substitute animal
and if you do not have a substitute
animal if you don't have a ram with your
four o'clock bushes then you have to
strangle the donkey now you're killing
the buck you're killing them we young
donkey either way but the important
thing inspector donkey must be strangled
because if it's strangled
you can't eat the meat because that's
blood so that's the main thing is you
know you use the Abraham story to show
that we will never again sacrifice
children and use the donkey stories say
we will never again eat donkeys
because donkeys worship the sacrality of
when dr. STV endowed this lecture sure
he never thought of following the fish
and decline into civilization to be
critical issues in international history
but I think that professor Bullock has
shown in fact that they are and I expect
that many other scholars will follow up
on this so with that I want to thank all
of you for coming and especially thank
professor bullets for this really
expansive and stimulating vision
so I can see you only one more